i'm about 30 kilometers outside
reykjavik in iceland and yes
earlier today i was swimming in power
plant wastewater
which is uh not something i'd usually
recommend if you're at a coal-fired
power plant
well even if you were just swimming in
the water that had been boiled to spin
the turbines and then
cooled back down again well there are
enough stories about coal ash
contamination with
arsenic and mercury and selenium that it
would not be safe
for gas and nuclear plants as long as
the water's treated on the way out
you'd probably be fine i think it's one
of those things where i wouldn't want to
chance it
but that blue white water is in the blue
lagoon now the management there are very
careful about how they phrase it they
prefer to talk about the skin care and
health benefits they claim come from the
silica in the water but
yeah it's geothermal power plant waste
water okay
quick diversion here most cities in the
world have a cold water main supply
there's a grid of cold water
to all the houses and buildings that's
heated on demand when it's needed in
each building
but iceland is geologically active in
parts of the country there are high
pressure reservoirs of hot water
not too far underground where
underground rivers meet hot rocks
in some places those reservoirs break
through and reach the surface
naturally so near those places it's
economical to drill
a borehole down to the ground and
capture the super-heated high-pressure
steam and water
that come back up there are two things
you can do with that hot water and steam
it's not drinkable first of all it's
filled with silica and other bits of
dissolved rock but
you can put it in a heat exchanger and
use it to heat up fresh
clean cold water and then you can send
the resulting clean hot water
down a pipeline to paying customers and
this is one of those pipelines there is
hot water speeding through this
to reykjavik it doesn't actually feel
warm if it did the pipe wouldn't be
doing its job because the water only
loses a couple of degrees
over dozens of kilometers but yes hot
water speeding through that icelandic
cities
have separate hot water and cold water
grids if your home is connected to that
grid you don't need a water heater
so okay that's hot water if you want
electricity instead
you can spin a turbine using the high
pressure steam that's coming up and
generate clean power that way
and technically you can do both but
pipelines are expensive and there is
a lot of hot water around here so often
it's just electricity
or hot water even a massive industrial
size geothermal borehole will last a few
decades before it starts to run out of
heat and
when that happens you can just open
another one a few kilometers away the
old one will get back up to temperature
sooner or later the earth is not going
to run out of heat
which means iceland has a massive supply
of hot water
high up on a hill above reykjavik there
is this beautiful building
called pearlan it's got exhibitions
about the natural wonders of iceland and
a revolving restaurant an observation
deck but
the big round things on the outside
aren't part of the exhibitions
they're the enormous hot water storage
tanks that the building was built around
pearlan is a water tower just like any
other you'd find around the world except
it stores hot water there's so much of
it that while it's not free
it's very very cheap if your house is a
bit too warm in winter in iceland you
don't turn the heating down you just
open a window and let some fresh air in
iceland also has
quite a lot of fresh air um when it's
snowing the pavements are heated up by
hot water pipes underneath
last time i was here was in winter the
lake behind city hall was frozen over
and the ice was strong enough to safely
walk on in one corner there is a pipe
constantly pouring a bit of hot water
into that lake just so the ducks have
somewhere to swim
and yes there are natural hot springs
elsewhere in iceland there are natural
hot spring beaches elsewhere in the
world but reykjavik
has an artificial hot water beach they
just pump hot water
into that lagoon to heat it up a bit
there's a hot tub down there
but that isn't power plant waste water
it's regular water like you get out of
the coal tap in your home
just heat it up in a heat exchanger by
the high pressure undrinkable water and
steam
that comes up from the boreholes of the
geothermal power plant so two never
touch
so there's one loose end here after that
high pressure steam comes up to the
surface and gets
used where does it go well once it's
cooled
down a bit the geothermal plants just
dump the water out onto nearby rocks
those rocks are permeable the water
slowly sinks through them and over
decades
it will make its way back to where it
came from
mostly when you're dumping that much
water out though it will
tend to form pools and lagoons
particularly when it's got a lot of
silica in it
and the story from there is simple
someone went bathing in one of those
pools
thought it helped the skin condition and
a few decades of construction and
marketing later
the blue lagoon is one of the wonders of
the world and they charge more than 30
euro for a basic ticket
and i don't want to knock that too much
because yes there is some research that
says bathing in geothermal water like
that helps some skin conditions and
there is a big difference between wild
swimming in a mysterious hot pool
and bathing in a well-regulated
geothermal spa that gives you a towel
and offers in-water massages but if you
feel like being cynical
then yes that is power plant
waste water
iceland is beautiful
bit wet but beautiful